(happy music)
- [Voiceover] This is Aiya and Shigu
two adorable clouded leopard cubs.
Don't be fooled by their youthful spirit.
Clouded leopards are some of the most shy,
mysterious and elusive cats.
Besides their shy nature,
they have a steadily declining population,
making it even harder to
spot them in the wild.
As far as big cats go, clouded
leopards are the smallest.
These two little girls will top out
at around three feet when fully grown.
Native throughout Asia, they
live in diverse habitats.
From the rainforests of Indonesia
to the foothills of the Himalayas.
They pack a powerful bite
too, as they have the largest
canine teeth relative to
body size of any wild cat.
They have short, powerful
legs and ankles that can
rotate backwards, making
them elite climbers.
Beyond a quickly shrinking habitat,
poaching remains a huge
problem, as their skin,
claws, teeth, bones and meat are all sold
on the black market.
This is the clouded leopard.